[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مع دخول الوسم تتلطف الاجواء وتهدا حراره
الارض ويبرد الماء والهوى فتتضر الاشجار
وترتاح المواشي فتدور اللبن وتقترب النوق
الموطيه من الولاده المسماه عند العرب
القدماء بالعشر من العشره وهي الابل التي
بلغت او قاربت في حملها سن العشرات شهور
وهي اغلى ما يملكه العرب من رؤوس الاموال
وهي مصدر عزه وثروه عندهم ولها مكانه عليا
ومن شده تتعلق بها قارن المولى تعطيلها
واهمالها وعدم الاهتمام بها بقرب القيامه
واذا الشمس كورت واذا النجوم انكدرت واذا
الجبال سيرت واذا العشاره
عطلت
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ولها اسماء متعدده عندهم على حسب اختلاف
الثقافاتي والازمنه الحوار هو الجمل اللي
توه مولود والحاشي هو الصغير والفاطر هو
الكبير هو الخلفه هي الناقه اللي يتبعه
ولده خلفه والخلوج هي الناقه اللي مات عنه
ولده قلب لها في مهجه القلب منزال مناييح
القصار شفنا الصحاري مراجل يشقى بها كره
رجال افلاس بايعها نواميس
شاري
[موسيقى]